hello and welcome to i almost said wired
hello not that i don't sympathize i'm
trying to put on a show all of this of
course brings the mind and what i say
all of this is cork i rewrote these late
last night so i think i have them in my
brain to better at this point they'll be
really scared and uncomfortable and
drawings was for a diving dress and no
this was not a fancy underground oh my
god or maybe they were just distracted
by the clearly visible strings sprouting
from their backs
it was eventually replaced by scuba gear
mostly because while wearing the
200-pound diving dress sailors could
only manage the strength to be the M in
the my CA B YMCA causing villainy were
barren bear name is Baron very good and
he's a talking Barracuda apparently all
of these fish were messed up on a leash
and medication because they took an
awkwardly long time to reply to each
other or maybe they apparently all these
fish
yeah guy have a tissue as well please
huh next up a symbol so cute it makes
the exclamation and hash marks question
their own sexuality loopy fluffy close I
didn't mean to the loopy fluffy you guys
I know fluffy curly loopy fluffy cozy
will be fluffy cozy with you hungry
honey boo people loopy fluffy cozy loopy
fluffy cozy Ruby fluffy close cozy I
said cozy I know I can do I just I my
brain is stupid so I can't concentrate
on things don't look like that Edison
was like oh no you can keep F up hurt
again
ah
wait it should be wet and I said what
what are the two
I'm gonna get canceled after all I don't
like the from the internet these very
lights are on because of Tesla and are
now off because of wired smartass script
supervisor